what do these things look like and
therefore
what kinds of ways do we have to
describe how this moves okay well let's
start with displacement here's my
displacement graph up the top it looks
just like a regular log curve except
it's been shifted one unit to the
left right okay now
therefore your um t equals zero
asymptote is really a t equals negative
one asymptote
and then when you draw it it should pass
through
oh i missed oh well sorry use your
imagination
you should pass through the origin right
now
that's terrible that's your game
here's a question for you i gave you
very little information when i described
the situation i just gave you the
equation and i told you a starting point
to know
what would you conclude therefore about
what kind of restriction we should make
on this i mean there's already a
restriction and the t is greater than
negative one not inclusive okay
what else would you say
could you are there any other
restrictions or is that is that the
graph
now see i would be inclined with no
other information right i would be
inclined to say actually
there's a restriction time is greater
than or equal to zero that tends to be
the assumption if you don't know
anything else okay particularly when
they say it starts somewhere right
it's like well
if this is where it starts where was it
before there was no before if i have
some part of the graph over here for
instance right like this point here i
would say well that's where it starts
like that's the real start right so
your kind of default is for time is
greater than or equal to zero unless the
question sort of provides to you some
situation where you know
at three o'clock i was here so obviously
there's a meaning to um negative time
you know it's before three o'clock okay
but here with no other kind of
conclusion that's what i've got all
right great now there's my displacement
function
what does my um velocity look like what
like before it looks just like a regular
hyperbola except
it's been shifted one unit to the left
okay
now again when you think about this
right it probably will help to actually
have some decent scale on here um this
part of the graph right i mean a normal
hyperbola looks like that doesn't it
okay so this is being moved one unit to
the left so i'm getting this kind of
shape
okay but in order to reflect the fact
that i mean up here my displacement
doesn't exist anywhere except for t is
greater than or equal to zero i'm going
to apply the same kind of restriction to
this ground okay so it looks like
something like this
is that okay is that gel
and of course we have that integer there
that should be one right t equals zero
you get one over one no problem okay and
you can already hopefully start to get
the gears turning in here for what this
implies about this what it tells you
what information it provides you about
the motion all right one last step
this is the graph we've got to come to
terms with how is it different to this
graph
it's upside down because of this
negative right but that's not the only
difference there's another difference
right
what does that mean
if i think about it this way right uh
let me think about it as um as t
approaches infinity okay both of these
are tending towards zero
right
but this one is tending
faster right because the denominator is
growing faster so therefore the dominant
is growing faster so the whole number is
approaching zero faster
it's pretty hard to actually reflect
that on the graph because the shape of
it is so simplistic but it's important
to keep in your head anyway
so
i would still have the same vertical
asymptote if i went there
i'll have the same horizontal asymptote
what's my x-intercept
it's negative one isn't it okay you can
get that just by putting time for zero
great
that's all the information we need ah i
should probably enable this too
now the question is
what's required when you have to
describe the motion you've got to put
this into words okay it's unfortunate
that we have to do this after the
english assessment isn't it but
there are three
very simple ingredients for describing
version okay and um
i used to see you know students who
sometimes they would take like actually
really is unfortunate this after english
now take a page and sometimes the motion
of a particle like this then take half a
page to describe it okay and in some
ways
there are a lot of things to say if you
wanted to say lots and lots and lots
right
but we don't we just want to wrap our
head around like basically
like actually as an hsc keyword i think
describe beans
um like identify key features that's a
general idea isn't it see i'm telling
you every single detail like what
you know i got up and i had breakfast
and then no you're just giving me the
big things and that's these three things
are so
no prizes for getting guessing what the
first thing is
ice cream
i'm gonna stop doing closed passages
with you twelve don't i
hey it's your apple is your ice cream
i see i see is not for ice cream
i see his for initial conditions okay
initial
conditions
you guys are worse than me okay anyway
now initial conditions what does that
include well you need to know
you need to know where you are
and you need to know
where you're going that's all
okay
so what that means is you need an x
value okay
x value now this is a bit tricky i admit
um i'm not sure how else to describe
this in a non-arbitrary way
this is an x it's a displacement
obviously this is referring
to where you're going going that's a
velocity is it
that tells you where you're going right
well i should say where you're going
right now here's the thing
they almost never care about almost
never unless they specify they don't
care about the velocity's value right
they don't want you to say um one meters
per second right the reason why is
because if i went and asked for every
single value this would take half a page
okay all we want to know is that you can
describe features off of what a graph
looks like okay so more often what they
really want
is just the sign
okay now what that translates to is you
would say the particle starts at the
origin
and is moving in the positive direction
that's what you'd say or it's moving up
or it's moving right whatever the
question provides to you okay so you
want an x value the actual position
where you are does matter and then you
want to know are you going up are you
going down are you not going anywhere
like that that would count as well if
this was a stationary point you would
say the object begins
at rest is the way the questions tend to
supply it
so sine would be
positive or negative or zero that is
relevant okay
right now when we're talking about major
features what might be the next
important thing that happens well you
want to know if this thing is moving
around and if this changes right if you
go somewhere else and then this you know
your movement in a particular direction
if it turns around or if it stops
so geometrically speaking what are those
places
stationary points well done
are there any station points on this
no
there are it's worth mentioning by the
way i'm talking about this guy up here
when i say station points i mean
stationary points for displacement not
stationary points down here or down here
if you're describing every single
feature of velocity and acceleration
again you're going to get half a page or
more actually
is no stationary points you need to know
um
not only where but this time
you need to know when
right so you want to tell me for
instance not in this case you know i
stopped at well i stopped you know two
meters to the right of the origin
after three seconds right so you want an
x value and t value
okay
stationary points includes when it
doesn't turn around when it just stops
okay um and then continues which i guess
would be a horizontal point of
inflection okay so this includes all of
those
if you
turn around then you should say your new
direction
if you
don't turn around you say then continues
in the in whichever direction you're
going okay but in a similar way it's up
here right you're providing a sort of
marker here's where i am the reason why
you don't need to provide a time here is
because it's the initial condition
but here it's like well where are you
when are you and what happens then
you stop turn around stop keep going the
same direction
okay now last one i won't make you guess
this one you need to tell the
the actual question where are you ending
up what is the final state of the
particle object whatever it is that's
moving okay
now this is tricky um
this is not like these these are actual
points usually okay and something
happens at those points now this is kind
of a bit of a wild western anything can
happen let's have a look at this right
how would you describe what this thing
is doing
as time approaches infinity that's what
this is
if there's no endpoint how would you
describe it
um well that's where you start to appeal
to your other graphs okay well i mean
you do appeal to other graphs all the
way through but here's where it's most
important okay
does it ever turn around again
no it doesn't otherwise you would have
described it up here okay you never have
turns down here because it's the final
state right
so therefore it's always going to be
moving after any stationary points i
have to describe it's always going to be
moving in the
positive direction and i can read that
off this
see how the sign of velocity is always
positive so i'm always going to move in
that direction
so that's talking about velocity but i'm
trying to describe the final state as t
approaches infinity so not only do i
want what the velocity is i want to know
what it's going toward and you can see
what it's going forward can't you right
so rather than saying the velocity of
the particle tends towards zero how
would you word that in a describing
motion sort of phrase
you'd say the particle's slowing down
and it's slowing down forever right does
it ever stop
no it never stops because
it never gets to the velocity never gets
to zero okay so you can see what i mean
by how do you describe this final state
it's difficult for me to give you a
checklist because for instance um you
know some particles do have an endpoint
and they stop and that's what they do
okay
if you're doing simple harmonic motion
obviously
you don't have a kind of it just keeps
on doing its thing right um but you need
to talk about where ends
so
let's do that now initial conditions
i've already sort of worded this but
let's write it down together okay
initially
we begin at the origin
okay
and we are moving in the
positive direction
i'm going to abbreviate a little bit
just because it takes me so long to
write things on the board but please do
write the full words okay
so that's that you may even like to put
down like you know just like a
mathematical induction um just headings
for yourself like okay this is my first
thing now i move on to the next thing
now it just so happens that in this case
there is no next thing it never turns
around okay
when i when i describe the final state
okay that final state actually describes
everything in between from initial
condition so this is part of why i chose
this it's a very boring example it's
simple to describe okay so there's
nothing under heading two for this
but under heading three right i would
say
the particle
continues because
it hasn't done any turn or anything like
that
it continues to move
in that direction
and i can say
slowing down forever but never stopping
okay
if i did have some stationary points
i might have to refer to i might have to
invoke this acceleration language in
here i'm have to say for example it
slows down and reaches such and such a
point
and then it keeps going or it slows down
and reaches such point and then it turns
around um all of that language will be
included here but thankfully i've got my
simple example that's it okay so there's
nothing too mystifying about describing
motion people get intimidated because
they're like oh words
commas full stops you know um but
all you're trying to do is interpret
that's all you're really doing okay and
you can be as minimalist as you want
some as you adequately describe the
motion